- personnellement ça ne me dérange pas
du tout je ne vois pas du tout pourquoi
l'interdire si on se respecte et chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut par
contre je suis peut-être contre dans les
écoles parce que dans les écoles et des
enfants sont là ils vont passer des amis
mais qu'est ce que ça va pas exclu que
sa maman
voyez on va pas mais en dehors de
l'école oui je suis les gens sont libres
on est dans un pays démocratique et
chacun a sa liberté chacun à niveau de
ce qu'elle a envie de faire ça me
dérange pas du tout le côté ça me
dérange concentrons passe quand à toi
s'il s'agit d'une simple foulard un truc
ou quoi
ne suit pas ça me gêne pas ce qui me
gêne c'est les habits entier surtout ce
qui me gêne c'est quand sont des jeunes
filles des petites filles voilà on va
pas du tout
vraiment pas du tout c'est pas un chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut enfin
ce qu'on appelle la liberté d'expression
et
mouassa a enlevé cette liberté je pense
que
on s'éloigne de la démocratie au voyage
après c'est un avis personnel
non ça me dérange pas dans la mesure où
je considère que à partir d'une personne
à partir du moment où une personne ne
pas à des droits du pays dans le
cadre et je crois pas en poils
le signe le pardessus une religieuse
serait une problématique
ça appartient à la personne et c'est pas
en portant des signes religieux qu'elle
est en train de 2,2
comment je pourrais dire ça de montrer
une forme de non appartenance au pays
dans lequel elle vit ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas quelque chose qui me dérange
tant que la personne le fait en étant
vraiment convaincu de sa religion et
qu'elle laisse une et qu'elle s'en sert
pas pour faire de la propagande et pour
essayer de faire paraître en avant sa
religion
ça me gêne pas après si on s'en sert
d'un côté un peu plus c'est là c'est
plus compliqué
franchement ça me dérange pas c'est la
liberté chacun pour moi chacun fait ce
qu'il veut
mais dans un pays libre
droit
moi ce que
pour avoir tenté le même si le religieux
par exemple chaque religion ben j'sais
religions toutes les religions c'est les
mêmes pour moi donc ce soir là où je
savais une chose je
le monde du jeu
dana saint-thierry mai
non ça ne dérange pas du tout on fait ce
qu'il veut et
on sait ce qu'il fait le ciel est à
voile intégral par exemple ça quand ou
alors des énormes froid quand on voit
quelle que soit sa ridicule
sinon
ça me dérange pas plus que ça